luxuriöse dienstwagen mit massagesitzen
es geht um teure beraterverträge und
heimliche boni und das alles auf kosten
der steuerzahler nicht der steuerzahler
soll der gebühren zu wir waren gerade
weil steuern
die rbb affäre um patricia schlesinger
die ja empört die republik und die
erschüttert die ard das ist wohl die
größte der größte skandal in der langen
geschichte des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks ist so lange nicht zu ende
denn es gibt immer weitere enthüllungen
um verschiedene ard sender jetzt jungs
beim ndr da geht es darum dass
redakteure schwere vorwürfe gegen die
sendeleitung erhoben haben es wird
kritische berichterstattung teils
unterdrückt von politischem filter ist
die rede und ja wir können nur sagen
tatort ard es ist dringend zeit für
echte reform im öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk